hello everyone thank you all for joining
my blitz Lee chess tournament for
subscribers this morning and it was a
great event for the seven players
applied congratulations to SRO for
winning first place
the Serbian knife for winning second
place although he did during the
tournament a bit late del Este for
winning third place I think
Ronaldinho was in fourth place and the
rajma tune was in fifth place and
yesterday I posted two videos both of
them were about 10 minutes long so for
today I prepared a very nice game by
Paul Morphy a nice short video you all
know Paul Morphy in the pride and sorrow
of Caixa
and this game he is playing against the
Frenchman Charlotte Carpentier and the
Carpentier is an amateur chess player
he's actually a writer and painter but
let's see how this game goes and
remember the first time I saw this game
how happy I was so I thought it might
make you happy as well and India
Morpheus playing this game without his
rook on a1 so a whole record morph is
white and he plays efore we have d5 from
Carpentier Knight to f3 Knight to c6 v 4
it's well a bit selector called is the
Scotch because what is already missing
or broken anyone but nevertheless V 4 so
we have e captures on d4 and now Bishop
to c4 so black is already up for rook
and the pawn we have Bishop to b4 check
by Carpentier and Morphy plays c3 so we
have D captures on c3 and now morphic
castles and now we have a/c captures on
v2 grabbing yet another pawn Morphy
plays Bishop captures on b2 and morph is
not present to capture this pawn on g7
and in this position our Carpentier is
already upper rook and two pawns and he
really shouldn't be too materialistic
about things but like I said LA
Carpentier is an amateur and he plays
Bishop to f8 he protected the g7 bond
this way so morphe goes a 5 trying to
stop this knight from going to s f6 we
have d6
Morphy plays rook to e1 and now we have
d captures on e5 and more C plays Knight
captures on e5 and in this position well
Carpentier says I'm not pro come up for
a couple of pounds let's exchange Queens
and I'm pretty sure I'm winning this
game so he plays Queen captures and d1
and this position Morphy plays Bishop
captures and f7 woods check and LA
Carpentier doesn't want to play the King
to d8 because he doesn't want to allow
more feet to capture his rook with check
so Carpentier polarize King to e7
and now morph in this position he plays
Knight to g6 check and this is a double
check from night on g6 and from rookin
e1 so the King has to move and yet again
LA Carpentier refuses to play the King
and the D file well so morphe couldn't
capture his queen with check so he
played King captures on f7 and now
morphe plays Knight captures on h8 and
well as you can see this is checkmate so
it's a it's a very nice checkmate and
it's a it's a beautiful position if
someone showed this to you on a diagram
you would you wouldn't probably believe
that this from an actual game but it
really is it's from the game or P
Carpentier and yeah like I said it will
be a short video today and I hope you
enjoyed this game by the great Paul
Morphy here you can check two of my
previous videos from yesterday if you
didn't have a chance to see them and I
will see you soon and once again
congratulations to the winners of the
tournament of this morning and and to
all participants it wouldn't be the same
without you so thank you all bye for now